this was the single worst day for the
footsie 100 benchmark index of shares
since 2008 since the financial crisis
and to put it into context well let's
have a look back at every single one of
the worst days going all the way back to
the start of the footsie back in 1984
you can see Black Monday 1987 they're
spread over two days actually got the
financial crisis as well and there it is
today March 2020 one of the worst days
ever the fifth worst and as well as
falls in asset prices in share prices
you also had Falls in oil prices down by
more than a fifth over the course of the
day
the UN's economic body their conference
on Trade and Development thinks we are
now facing the prospect of a global
recession what does that mean well
economists broadly think that anything
under 2.5 percent growth across the
world constitutes a recession it's
actually very unusual look back over the
course of recent history can see the
dot-com crash there the financial crisis
were a big dip there and recently the
expectation was the economy was going to
rebound you're gonna have a little bit
of stronger growth in the next few years
well actually I'm sad think the more
likely prospect is about 1.7 percent
growth a thing that's worth about a
trillion dollars off global incomes and
all of those concerns whether it's about
covert 19 whether it's about oil are
causing very strange things to happen in
the bond market this is where
governments borrow and just let this go
talk is all the way back to 1703 you can
see interest rates faced by the
government says government debt
government interest rates go all the way
back to that period they are the lowest
now that they have been in history the
lowest since the beginning of capitalism
just shows how concerned investors are
they're willing to lend the government
money and incredibly low interest rates